Sierra Crane Murdoch has been on our show before. She reports on Indigenous communities out west. Back in 2023, she got a call from a man in Montana, Kevin Howard. He said his daughter Mika had been killed in a hit-and-run. Local police were dragging their feet. He thought the driver might get away with it. The driver was white. Mika was Native, a citizen of the Blackfeet Nation.
Sierra Crane Murdoch 曾经上过我们的节目。她报道过西部原住民社区。早在2023年，她接到了一位蒙大拿州男子Kevin Howard的电话。他说他的女儿Mika在一次肇事逃逸事故中丧生。当地警方办事拖沓。他担心肇事者会逍遥法外。肇事者是白人，而Mika是原住民，是黑脚族（Blackfeet Nation）的公民。
Lots of Native people are killed in hit-and-runs, and the drivers are rarely brought to justice. And Sierra thought she might be able to document why by diving into Mika's case, because Mika's parents had recordings of nearly all their interactions with law enforcement. Mika's parents did some other things, too. They were very strategic and did some extraordinary things other families had not tried to make sure Mika's case was one that the authorities could not ignore.
许多原住民在肇事逃逸中丧生，而肇事者很少受到法律制裁。Sierra认为，通过深入了解Mika的案件，她或许能够记录下其中的原因，因为Mika的父母几乎录下了他们与执法部门的所有互动。Mika的父母还做了其他一些事情。他们非常有策略地采取了一些非同寻常的行动，这是其他家庭从未尝试过的，旨在确保Mika的案件是当局无法忽视的。
That story and how it unfolded, and what it's like to be a couple making that happen, that's going to be our whole show today. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And with that, I hand it over to Sierra.
那个故事，它是如何展开的，以及作为一对为此付出的夫妻是什么样的感受，这将是我们今天节目的全部内容。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。接下来，我把话筒交给Sierra。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Mika's family lives on the Flathead Indian Reservation. It's in a valley, surrounded by big, toothy mountains. Mika was 22 years old the night she was killed. She'd been out with her younger brother. They'd gone to a bar to buy cigarettes. On their way home, Mika couldn't find her phone and thought she'd left it at the bar. She told her brother to let her out of the car. She'd go back to the bar to get it, and then she'd walk home.
Mika的家人住在弗拉特黑德印第安人保留地（Flathead Indian Reservation）。它位于一个山谷中，四周环绕着高大、嶙峋的山脉。Mika在遇害的那晚年仅22岁。她当时和弟弟一起出去。他们去了一家酒吧买烟。在回家的路上，Mika找不到手机，以为把它落在了酒吧。她让弟弟让她下车，她要回酒吧找手机，然后再走回家。
Hours later, around 4:00 AM, a tribal police officer found her body on the side of the road, Highway 93. The officer, a friend of Kevin's, drove to his house and woke him up.
几小时后，大约凌晨4点，一名部落警官在93号高速公路路边发现了她的尸体。这名警官是Kevin的朋友，他开车来到Kevin家并叫醒了他。
They told us Mika was deceased. And then right away, I was like, well, did you guys get him? And they were like, yeah, it was some tweaker from Butte. And in my mind, I was like, just, like, happy that they apprehend, you know? And I just-- I gave the cops a hug, and I was like, thank you guys, or whatever. I'm glad that you guys were there.
他们告诉我们Mika去世了。我当时立刻就问：“你们抓住他了吗？”他们说：“是的，是一个来自比尤特（Butte）的吸毒者。”我当时心里还挺高兴，他们抓住了凶手，你知道吗？我甚至还拥抱了警察，我说：“谢谢你们，我很庆幸有你们在。”
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Later that day, Kevin and his wife Carissa Heavy Runner, Mika's mother, took a cross and a teddy bear to the roadside where she'd been found. When they got there, investigators from Montana Highway Patrol were flying a drone, photographing the scene. One of them was named Wayne Bieber. He asked Kevin and Carissa if they had Mika's phone. It had actually been in her brother's car that night, slipped between her seat and the console. Bieber said he needed it. Carissa couldn't understand why.
那天晚些时候，Kevin和他的妻子Carissa Heavy Runner（Mika的母亲）带着一个十字架和一只泰迪熊来到了发现Mika尸体的路边。当他们到达时，蒙大拿州公路巡警的调查人员正在放无人机拍摄现场。其中一人名叫Wayne Bieber。他问Kevin和Carissa有没有Mika的手机。手机其实当晚就在她弟弟的车里，滑进了座椅和中控台之间。Bieber说他需要这个手机。Carissa不明白为什么。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: He was adamant about following us home to get it. And I repeated, she did not have her phone on her. It was in her brother's car. Why do you need it? What's it going to show, or whatever? And then he said, we need to look at all aspects. I was torn. I fought with myself, and I thought I was helping. And so I gave him the phone up here at our house.
他坚持要跟着我们回家拿手机。我反复说，她身上没带手机，它就在她弟弟的车里。你为什么要它？它能显示什么之类的？然后他说，我们需要查看所有方面。我很纠结。我在心里挣扎，以为自己在帮忙。所以我就在我们家门口把手机给了他。
When you're handing it to him, I was like, oh, Mika is just freaking, just, pissed off right now. Like, she would not like this at all. And I said that out loud. Shouldn't have done it-- but in a joking manner, I guess. But I really did feel that way. Like, Mika's like, no, no, don't give it to him.
当我把它递给他时，我心想，天哪，Mika现在肯定气疯了。她绝对不会喜欢这样的。我大声说了出来。我不该这么做的——但我当时大概是开玩笑的语气。但我确实是那种感觉。好像Mika在说，不，不，别给他。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Yeah, will you tell me more about that?
是的，你能多告诉我一些关于那件事吗？
Like, if you knew Mika-- probably the most stubborn person I know. Like, she would just fight tooth and nail over the dumbest thing to the bitter end.
如果你认识Mika——她大概是我认识的最固执的人。就像，即使是为了最愚蠢的事情，她也会抗争到底，绝不退让。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Mika was constantly challenging her parents, but not in a get-in-trouble kind of way. They were close. Back when she was a teenager, when she realized marijuana eased her anxiety, instead of lying to them, she crafted a PowerPoint presentation about its medical benefits.
Mika经常挑战她的父母，但不是那种会惹麻烦的方式。他们关系很亲密。当她还是个十几岁的孩子时，当她意识到大麻可以缓解焦虑时，她没有对父母撒谎，而是精心制作了一份关于大麻医疗益处的幻灯片演示。
She wrote poetry. She was really into philosophy, especially the Tao. Breaking the Habit of Being Yourself was the title of the book she was reading when she died. Also, she was loud.
她写诗。她非常喜欢哲学，尤其是《道德经》。她去世时正在读的书名为《打破成为自己的习惯》。而且，她嗓门很大。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: You could hear her, like, probably even in the garage, just laughing. And her laugh was just so loud. Her sound just echoed. Or if she was mad, just like, ha! Like, just had to let that energy out and (LAUGHING) just things like that she would do-- run into our room, fart, run away-- just laughing all the way. She was like that.
你甚至能在车库里听到她笑。她的笑声太响亮了。她的声音会回荡。如果她生气了，就像“哈！”一定要把那股劲儿发泄出来，（笑）她会做那种事——跑进我们房间，放个屁，然后跑开——一路笑着。她就是那样的人。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: A week after Mika's death, Kevin got a text from a friend. The driver who killed Mika wasn't in jail, like he'd been told. Her name was Sunny White. She was 28 years old. Police were looking for her, not because she'd killed Mika, but because she'd allegedly just kidnapped her two kids. There was a police alert out for her.
Mika去世一周后，Kevin收到朋友发来的短信。杀害Mika的肇事者并没有像他们被告知的那样在监狱里。她的名字叫Sunny White，28岁。警方当时在找她，不是因为她杀了Mika，而是因为她涉嫌刚刚绑架了自己的两个孩子。当时有一个警方通缉令。
And it had the names of the kids and all that.
上面还有孩子们的名字之类的信息。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: She had a four-year-old daughter named Aryan, and I believe a two-year-old son named Nation.
她有一个4岁的女儿叫Aryan，还有一个我相信是2岁的儿子叫Nation。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Aryan and Nation. Carissa also got a text from a friend around the same time.
Aryan和Nation。Carissa大约在同一时间也收到了朋友的短信。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: She said that a tribal police officer pulled over a woman, a non-Native, and she had said, I came here to kill an Indian. I remember I was just speechless after that. It's just, like, thinking, could it have been a hate crime? Could she have driven by, turned around, came back, and hit her and thought, oh, I'm not going to get caught?
她说一名部落警官拦住了一名非原住民女性，那女人说：“我来这儿就是为了杀个印第安人。”我记得听到这话后简直说不出话来。这让我心想，这会是一起仇恨犯罪吗？她是不是开车经过，掉头回来，撞倒了她，然后心想，“哦，我不会被抓到的”？
We were always warned as kids, you've got to watch out. Nazis and stuff, they'll intentionally just-- that's how they get away with killing Indians. They just run them over on the side of the road. And so, to me, it was like, holy shit, this is real. This is what happened, you know? She was murdered.
我们小时候一直被警告，要小心。纳粹之类的家伙，他们会故意……他们就是这样通过杀害印第安人来逃脱惩罚的。他们就在路边直接开车撞死他们。所以对我来说，这就像是，天哪，这是真的。这就是发生的现实，你知道吗？她是谋杀。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Carissa and Kevin had so many questions. First, why wasn't Sunny White in jail? Hours after she hit and killed Mika, Sunny had been arrested for child endangerment, not vehicular homicide. They'd learned she spent seven days in jail and then was released, the charges dropped.
Carissa和Kevin有很多疑问。首先，为什么Sunny White没被关进监狱？在撞死Mika几小时后，Sunny因为危害儿童罪被捕，而不是过失杀人罪。他们后来得知她在监狱里待了7天就被释放了，指控也被撤销了。
Also, what happened to that investigator from the Montana Highway Patrol, Wayne Bieber, who took Mika's phone? He'd promised to call, but he never did. Carissa and Kevin started blowing up his phone. They called every day for a week-- nothing. Then a friend dialed him from her phone, a number he didn't recognize, and he picked up.
还有，那个拿走Mika手机的蒙大拿州公路巡警调查员Wayne Bieber怎么了？他答应过会打电话，但从未打过。Carissa和Kevin开始狂轰滥炸他的手机。他们整整一周每天都打，没反应。后来，一个朋友用他没认出来的号码拨通了电话，他接了。
Can I ask who was calling again one more time? Sorry about that.
我能再问一次是谁打来的吗？很抱歉。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Carissa Heavy Runner, the mother of Mika Westwolf. You gave me your number when we were putting a cross on the side of the road, and there was you and another trooper there.
我是Carissa Heavy Runner，Mika Westwolf的母亲。我们在路边立十字架的时候你给了我号码，当时你和另一个警官在那儿。
Yep. So I haven't gotten-- I've been-- to be honest with you, I've been running around with my head cut off the last couple of weeks, trying to get caught up on a bunch of other stuff. Have you talked to anybody else as far as things go?
是的。老实说，过去几周我忙得不可开交，一直在试图处理一大堆别的事情。关于案子的情况，你们和别人谈过吗？
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: No, because I don't know who else to talk to.
没有，因为我不知道还能找谁谈。
I've had some other things coming up with work that I've been trying to get taken care of.
最近工作上出现了一些其他事情，我一直在试图处理。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Bieber tells Carissa he's applied for some warrants and then keeps talking about how busy he is.
Bieber告诉Carissa他已经申请了一些搜查令，然后继续喋喋不休说他有多忙。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Just, how come-- how come she's not in jail still?
只是，为什么……为什么她还没被关在监狱里？
So it's one of those things. She was put in jail. We still have to finish up with the rest of our investigation.
这是其中之一。她确实被关过。我们仍然必须完成调查的其余部分。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Mm-hmm.
嗯。
And that includes waiting for toxicology stuff to come back, along with trying to get everything in line that may be associated with evidence for that.
这包括等待毒理学报告结果，同时试图理顺所有可能与证据相关的东西。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: OK.
好的。
I will try and get back to you as soon as I can, but to be honest with you, every time I try and seem to do something lately, it ends up going to poop, and I end up not going in the direction that I wanted to go for the day to try and get some stuff done.
我会尽我所能尽快回复你们，但老实说，最近我试着做点什么，结果总是一团糟，最后我这一天都没能朝着我想要的方向完成工作。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: OK.
好的。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: How confident did you feel in the investigation at that point?
在那时，你对调查有多大信心？
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Not confident at all. [CHUCKLES]
完全没有信心。[轻笑]
He told us on the phone, oh, everything I touch turns to poop. Yeah.
他在电话里对我们说，“哦，我经手的每一件事都变成一团糟。”是的。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Everything I touch turns to poop.
每一件事都变成一团糟。
And I'm just thinking, like, that's not what you want to hear. Like, it'd be funny if it was, I guess--
我当时就在想，这不是你想听到的。如果那是真的倒也滑稽——
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: This is who's investigating our daughter's case. This is who we're supposed to rely on to give us information and who we're supposed to trust.
这就是正在调查我们女儿案件的人。这就是我们应该依靠来获取信息、应该信任的人。
Like, this guy is inept.
这家伙简直无能。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: I asked Montana Highway Patrol several times for an interview with Wayne Bieber, but they declined.
我多次向蒙大拿州公路巡警申请采访Wayne Bieber，但他们拒绝了。
Sierra Crane Murdoch. Coming up, Kevin and Carissa realize that if they want anything to happen in the case, they'll need to take matters into their own hands-- which they do. Stay with us.
我是Sierra Crane Murdoch。稍后，Kevin和Carissa意识到，如果他们想让案件有所进展，他们必须亲自动手——他们也确实这么做了。请留在这里。
It's This American Life. Sierra Crane Murdoch picks up the story of Mika Westwolf and her parents.
这是《美国生活》。Sierra Crane Murdoch继续讲述Mika Westwolf和她父母的故事。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: The distrust Native families have of law enforcement is centuries old. Starting in the 1860s, the US troops that had been stationed on reservations were replaced with police forces. These police took Native children from their families to send to boarding schools, arrested holy men for practicing religious ceremonies, and quelled rebellions.
原住民家庭对执法部门的不信任已有几个世纪的历史。从19世纪60年代开始，驻扎在保留地的美国军队被警察部队取代。这些警察将原住民儿童从家中带走送往寄宿学校，逮捕因举行宗教仪式而逮捕的神职人员，并镇压叛乱。
It was the role of law enforcement on reservations to control Native people before it was to keep them safe. Police were there to protect white settlers who lived on and around reservations. Meanwhile, a lot of crimes affecting tribal citizens were never investigated or prosecuted.
保留地执法部门的作用在维护安全之前，主要是为了控制原住民。警察的存在是为了保护生活在保留地及其周边的白人定居者。与此同时，许多影响部落公民的犯罪从未得到调查或起诉。
In the 1960s, the federal government turned over its jurisdiction on the Flathead reservation to the state of Montana, but Montana has been reluctant to spend money on policing the reservation, and tribal members' distrust of law enforcement has only grown.
20世纪60年代，联邦政府将弗拉特黑德保留地的司法管辖权移交给了蒙大拿州，但蒙大拿州一直不愿在保留地的警务上投入资金，部落成员对执法部门的不信任感有增无减。
Carissa and Kevin were convinced Bieber wasn't investigating Mika's case, so they tried investigating on their own. They started working with a tribal advocate who helps families of murder victims. Her name is Erica Shelby. She knocked on every door within a few miles of where Mika was killed, looking for surveillance footage and witnesses. One business had a direct view. She connected Carissa and Kevin with a lawyer to make sure the business preserved the footage.
Carissa和Kevin确信Bieber没有在调查Mika的案子，所以他们试图自己调查。他们开始与一位帮助谋杀受害者家庭的部落倡导者合作。她的名字叫Erica Shelby。她在Mika遇害地点方圆几英里内敲了每一扇门，寻找监控录像和证人。有一家企业正好可以看到现场。她帮Carissa和Kevin联系了一位律师，以确保该企业保留了录像。
We are doing stuff, the way that he was talking--
我们正在做一些事情，就他说话的方式来看——
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Three weeks after Mika's death, Bieber finally visited Kevin and Carissa at their house. They remember him standing awkwardly in the kitchen. Carissa is seated at the kitchen island. Kevin is in a recliner behind her. Erica is there, too, taking notes. The meeting feels tense, restrained. They can't get an answer to their main question, why wasn't Sunny White behind bars?
Mika去世三周后，Bieber终于到他们家拜访了。他们记得他尴尬地站在厨房里。Carissa坐在厨房岛旁。Kevin在她身后的躺椅上。Erica也在场做记录。会面气氛紧张且克制。他们无法得到核心问题的答案：为什么Sunny White没有被关进监狱？
I mean, to be honest, it's just strange that if she was, in fact, charged, why is she not in jail?
我的意思是，老实说，如果她确实被起诉了，为什么她还没进监狱，这太奇怪了。
We have to look at everything as the totality. So Montana law, if you are intoxicated, you are not allowed to be on the roadway. You cannot even be on the shoulder. You have to be walking off into the ditch or using a designated walk path.
我们必须全面审视一切。根据蒙大拿州法律，如果你喝醉了，是不允许在马路上行走的。你甚至不能在路肩上。你必须走到沟里或者使用指定的步行道。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: A walk path. He's not talking about Sunny White's intoxication. He's talking about Mika's. This is the first time anyone in law enforcement has mentioned to Kevin and Carissa that Mika might have been drunk.
步行道。他谈的不是Sunny White的醉酒情况。他谈的是Mika的。这是执法部门的人第一次向Kevin和Carissa提到Mika可能喝醉了。
It's also the first time anyone has told them that being drunk and walking on the side of the road is a crime in Montana. And it's the first time anyone has suggested that if you get hit, your drunkenness could mean your death was your own fault. Then their tribal advocate, Erica asks--
这也是第一次有人告诉他们，在蒙大拿州，喝醉了走在路边是违法的。这也是第一次有人暗示，如果你被撞了，你的醉酒可能意味着你的死亡是你自己的错。然后他们的部落倡导者Erica问——
So but what does that have to do with her being out?
那么这和她当时在外面有什么关系？
The totality of the circumstances, looking back at the whole thing as an offense--
考虑到所有情况，把整件事看作一个违法行为——
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: "The totality of the circumstances"-- Bieber will repeat this phrase 11 times in the recording. It's pretty vague what he means, and you hear Kevin trying to get Bieber to clarify, to pick apart his logic.
“考虑到所有情况”——Bieber在录音中重复了这句话11次。他想表达的意思非常模糊，你可以听到Kevin试图让Bieber澄清，试图剖析他的逻辑。
Well, I mean, it's-- if the other person was in violation of the law as well, wouldn't Mika be charged with intoxicated on a roadway, and then the other person be charged with vehicular homicide because she was intoxicated, driving, operating a vehicle?
我的意思是，如果对方也违反了法律，难道不应该指控Mika在路上醉酒，然后指控对方过失杀人，因为她酒后驾驶、操作车辆吗？
That is why I am saying review.
这就是为什么我说要审查。
So Mika's toxicology, though, came back where she was impaired?
那么，Mika的毒理学报告显示她受到影响了吗？
So these are things that take time in order to process, OK?
这些事情处理起来需要时间，好吗？
Well, right. I guess my concern would be, like, that's kind of your justification for her not being currently in jail, would be Mika's potential intoxication?
对。我猜我担心的点在于，你为她目前没有入狱提供的辩护理由，是不是Mika可能醉酒了？
The question that we come back to is exactly what I was telling you, was if you are intoxicated and walking on the road--
我们回到刚才说的那个问题，如果你喝醉了走在路上——
But we don't know that, right?
但我们并不知道那点，对吧？
OK. The totality of the circumstances of this--
好的。考虑到这件事的所有情况——
OK.
好的。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Kevin asks him if he's gathering any of the surveillance footage from the night Mika was killed, the footage they'd been working to preserve. Maybe this could tell them something, like if Sunny swerved, or if she stopped when she hit Mika, or sped up.
Kevin问他是否正在收集Mika遇害当晚的任何监控录像，也就是他们一直努力保存的录像。也许这能告诉他们一些信息，比如Sunny是否转向了，或者她在撞到Mika后是停下了还是加速了。
What would be that you're trying to look for?
你到底想找什么？
Anything and everything, to get the total grasp of the situation. Like, for instance, if it is a white supremacist, maybe it was an intentional hit and run. So now all of a sudden, it's deliberate homicide, and we're not investigating it as such.
任何和一切，以全面掌握情况。例如，如果那是白人至上主义者，也许这是故意的肇事逃逸。那么突然之间，这就是蓄意谋杀，而我们却没有按那种方式进行调查。
What is it that you're--
你到底——
I mean, it's about--
我的意思是，关于——
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: And her children's names, Aryan and Nation.
还有她孩子们的名字，Aryan和Nation。
I can't tell you how to name your child.
我不能告诉你怎么给孩子起名。
Yeah, but if you name your kids Aryan and Nation, chances are you're an affiliate.
是的，但如果你给孩子起名Aryan和Nation，很有可能你是他们的同伙。
I can't look at it as that. And I shouldn't look at it as that.
我不能那样看。我不应该那样看。
Well, then you shouldn't look at it as Mika was drunk on the side of the road. So we don't-- we treat it--
好吧，那你也不应该把Mika看作是在路边喝醉的人。所以我们不——我们对待它的方式——
That's not the way I'm looking at it.
那不是我的看法。
To me--
对我来说——
I can tell you've got pent-up aggression.
我看得出来你压抑了愤怒。
Whoa. No, no, no, no. To me--
哇。不，不，不，不。对我来说——
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Carissa is quiet. She's now suspicious of Bieber. He has Mika's phone with him, and he asks her for the code to open and search it. She refuses.
Carissa很安静。她现在对Bieber产生了怀疑。他随身带着Mika的手机，并向她索要解锁搜索的密码。她拒绝了。
I have to take this.
我必须把这个拿走。
Why do you have to take it?
你为什么要把它拿走？
I have to seal this up now because this goes into-- I have to go apply for a warrant.
我现在必须把它封存，因为这涉及——我必须去申请搜查令。
So can we hold on to it until you get the warrant?
那么在我们拿到搜查令之前，我们能保管它吗？
No.
不行。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: He says no. Kevin told me Bieber held up the phone in an evidence bag, sealed it shut.
他说不行。Kevin告诉我，Bieber把手机举在一个证据袋里，密封起来。
So I guess I'm confused as to-- that's our property. That's my property. That wasn't--
所以我很困惑——那是我们的财产。那是我的财产。那并不是——
Actually--
事实上——
--on the scene.
——在现场的。
And now it has to get a warrant to collect any information that may be valuable to the investigation.
现在必须拿到搜查令才能收集可能对调查有价值的任何信息。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: I can tell you 100% after that we knew that we spooked him, you know? And so you could tell he was clearly mad after that. You could tell he was flustered. I wish we would have recorded him trying to leave our driveway.
我可以百分之百地告诉你，在那之后我们知道我们吓到他了，对吧？你可以看出他那之后显然很生气。你可以看出他很慌乱。我真希望我们录下了他试图离开我们车道的过程。
He went around the light pole thing once because he didn't know which way he was going, and he had trouble trying to back up. And it's like, his tires were just spinning. And we're just standing at the window laughing, and I was like, did that really just happen?
他绕着电线杆转了一圈，因为他不知道该往哪走，而且他在倒车时遇到了困难。轮胎一直在空转。我们站在窗边笑着，我心想，这真的发生了吗？
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: When the Montana Highway Patrol applied for the warrant to search Mika's phone, it listed intoxication while walking on a road as the crime they were investigating, not the crime that killed Mika.
当蒙大拿州公路巡警申请搜查Mika手机的许可时，它列出的犯罪调查对象是路边行走时醉酒，而不是杀害Mika的罪行。
Carissa and Kevin have been together for 18 years. Carissa is Native, Blackfeet and Diné. Kevin is white, but he grew up on the Flathead reservation. A lot of his family is Salish Kootenai, including his son. They met as single parents when Kevin's son was three years old and Mika was six. They became a tight family unit. Kevin built them a house at the foot of the mountains. Their albums are full of photos of them camping and hunting together. They told me Mika was a good shot, but she always intentionally missed.
Carissa和Kevin已经在一起18年了。Carissa是原住民，黑脚族和纳瓦霍族（Diné）。Kevin是白人，但他是在弗拉特黑德保留地长大的。他的家人很多是萨利什库特奈人（Salish Kootenai），包括他的儿子。他们是以单亲家长的身份相识的，那时Kevin的儿子3岁，Mika 6岁。他们成为了一个紧密的家庭单元。Kevin在山脚下为他们盖了一栋房子。他们的相册里全是他们一起露营和打猎的照片。他们告诉我Mika枪法很好，但她总是故意打偏。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: How has losing Mika impacted your marriage?
失去Mika对你们的婚姻有什么影响？
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: It's been hard. I find myself where Kevin's wanting to get me outside, go take a ride up the mountain, and then I'm being reluctant because I'm already thinking in the back of my mind, this is going to make me sad. I'm going to cry. I don't want to do-- you know? And I feel bad about that because I know he's just trying to get me outside and do the things that we love and Mika loved.
很难。我发现自己有时Kevin想带我出去，去山上兜兜风，但我却很不情愿，因为我脑海里已经想到，这会让我想起伤心事。我会哭的。我不想那样……你知道吗？我为此感到抱歉，因为我知道他只是想带我出去，做我们喜欢做的事，也是Mika喜欢做的事。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: There's a saying about the highway Mika died on-- "Pray for me. I drive 93." Carissa and Kevin could name three other Native people who had been killed in the last five years while walking this same stretch of highway. In none of those cases had the driver been prosecuted or even arrested. They wanted to know why.
关于Mika去世的那条公路有一句谚语——“为我祈祷，我行驶在93号公路上”。Carissa和Kevin能叫出过去五年里在同一路段行走时被杀害的三名原住民的名字。在这些案件中，没有一起案件的司机被起诉甚至逮捕。他们想知道为什么。
So a few weeks after their meeting with Bieber, they invited the mothers of the victims over to their house for dinner. They all sat in the living room. It was a little awkward. Bonnie Ascencio's daughter Maureena was killed in 2022.
所以，在与Bieber会面几周后，他们邀请了受害者的母亲们到家里吃晚餐。她们都坐在客厅里。气氛有点尴尬。Bonnie Ascencio的女儿Maureena于2022年去世。
I wasn't sure what to say or what to do. It was a little bit solemn, kind of. And then when I started talking about Bieber calling me, they were just like, oh, my gosh!
我当时不知道该说什么或做什么。气氛有点庄重。然后当我开始谈论Bieber给我打电话时，她们简直惊呆了！
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: They learned they'd all had the same investigator, Wayne Bieber, and the same county prosecutor, James Lapotka, who Carissa and Kevin hadn't heard from yet.
她们了解到她们找的都是同一个调查员Wayne Bieber，以及同一个县检察官James Lapotka，Carissa和Kevin还没联系过他。
I remember I was like, what the fuck? Serious?
我记得当时我说，“搞什么鬼？认真的吗？”
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: We all looked at each other, us, all our friends, and, like, oh, my gosh, we cannot let them get away with this. Same lead prosecutor, same lead investigator.
我们互相看着，我们所有人，我们的朋友们，心想，天哪，我们不能让他们逃脱惩罚。同一个首席检察官，同一个首席调查员。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Maureena was Bonnie's second child to die on the road. Her first, Ruby, had been riding with a friend when he crashed their car and killed her. He was intoxicated. He survived.
Maureena是Bonnie第二个死在路上的孩子。第一个，Ruby，在朋友驾驶时出了车祸并杀害了她。他酒后驾车。他幸存了下来。
Bonnie says the friend told Bieber that Ruby had been driving, but Bonnie's family didn't believe him. They did their own investigation, found witnesses, including a farmer who said he'd seen the friend in the driver's seat. He went to prison. But if Bonnie and her family hadn't investigated, he might not have been charged.
Bonnie说那个朋友告诉Bieber是Ruby开的车，但Bonnie一家不相信他。他们进行了自己的调查，找到了证人，包括一名农民，他说他看到那个朋友在驾驶座上。他进了监狱。但如果Bonnie和她的家人没有去调查，他可能根本不会被起诉。
Two years later, when Maureena died, no one was charged, even though the Montana Highway Patrol knew who the driver was and, the family says, told them that she was over the legal limit for THC. Bonnie met with the county prosecutor, James Lapotka.
两年后，Maureena去世时，没有人被起诉，尽管蒙大拿州公路巡警知道司机是谁，而且家人说他们曾告诉他们，她体内的THC含量超标。Bonnie会见了县检察官James Lapotka。
They told us specifically at that meeting that they could not win a case if they pressed charges, that it just wasn't enough. And he said, I just know. I've done enough of it. I know that we can't win. And I'm not going to take a case to court that I can't win.
在那次会议上，他们明确告诉我们，如果他们提出指控，他们打不赢官司，证据不足。他说：“我就是知道。我处理过够多案子了。我知道我们打不赢。我不会把一场打不赢的官司带到法庭上。”
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: It felt to Bonnie like Lapotka had written her daughter off. She obsessed over the particulars of her daughter's case. She wanted to rent a billboard on the highway and brainstormed messages, like, how hard is it to gather evidence? And whose reservation is this? And who is protecting who? But she didn't have money for a billboard. She checked herself into the mental health department at a hospital.
对于Bonnie来说，感觉就像Lapotka已经放弃了她的女儿。她沉迷于女儿案件的细节。她想在高速公路上租一块广告牌，并构思了一些信息，比如，“收集证据有多难？”、“这是谁的保留地？”以及“谁在保护谁？”但她没钱租广告牌。她把自己住进了医院的心理健康科。
I talked to another mother, Tricia Finley. Her son, Aiden, was killed in a hit and run in 2018. She says it was almost six years before anyone in law enforcement shared anything with her about her son's case. The county attorney, Lapotka, invited her to his office. A witness to Aiden's death had come forward and named the driver. But there was a problem-- Bieber had taken four months to locate the driver and get his confession. During that time, the statute of limitations had passed.
我采访了另一位母亲，Tricia Finley。她的儿子Aiden在2018年的一起肇事逃逸中丧生。她说过了近六年，执法部门才有人与她分享关于她儿子案件的任何情况。县检察官Lapotka邀请她到办公室。Aiden死亡的一名目击者挺身而出并指认了司机。但有一个问题——Bieber花了四个月才找到司机并获得他的供词。在此期间，诉讼时效已经过了。
So they couldn't find him from November until April.
所以他们从11月到4月都没能找到他。
That's what it looks like. Honestly, if all of this police work would have been wrapped up in November, we could charge him. But--
看起来就是这样。老实说，如果所有这些警务工作都在11月完成，我们就能起诉他了。但是——
Why wasn't it?
为什么没完成？
Because we didn't get--
因为我们没能——
Because they couldn't find him?
因为他们找不到他？
That's what it looks like.
看起来是这样。
[SCOFFS]
[嗤之以鼻]
Because I'd have had until the first week in December--
因为我本来有时间处理到12月的第一周——
But they knew where he lived. I mean, it's not that hard to find somebody.
但他们知道他住在哪。我的意思是，找人并不难。
My guess is they weren't in a really big hurry to do anything in November and probably, they didn't understand that there was a statute of limitations window closing. I bet they weren't paying attention to that at all.
我猜他们11月的时候并不怎么着急做任何事，而且可能，他们根本不知道诉讼时效窗口正在关闭。我打赌他们根本就没注意那个。
[SNIFFLES]
[抽泣]
[SIGHS]
[叹息]
Isn't that their job, though?
这不是他们的工作吗？
Yeah. Yeah, it is.
是的。是的，确实是。
So because of that--
所以因为这样——
[CRYING]
[哭泣]
--there's-- like, they're going to get away with it?
——他们就要逃脱惩罚了？
I hope not, but that's a possibility.
我希望不会，但那是种可能。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: The driver did get away with it. Lapotka couldn't find a way to charge the case. I reached out to Montana Highway Patrol about Bonnie and Tricia's cases, but they declined to answer my questions.
肇事者确实逃脱了惩罚。Lapotka找不到起诉案件的办法。我联系了蒙大拿州公路巡警询问关于Bonnie和Tricia案件的情况，但他们拒绝回答我的问题。
There were two harms when Mika was killed, the first when she was hit, the second when she was left on the side of the road to die alone. Nationally, Native pedestrians are six times likelier to be killed in a hit and run than white pedestrians. I tried to figure out why.
Mika遇害时有两次伤害，第一次是她被撞时，第二次是她被留在路边孤独死去时。在全国范围内，原住民行人被肇事逃逸杀害的可能性是白人行人的六倍。我试图找出原因。
I learned that when states were building their highway systems in the 1920s and '30s, they put them through reservations instead of around them, because if they ran through reservations, the federal government had to pick up the tab. Fewer Native people own cars, so they're more likely to be walking along these roads. They're dying where there are no sidewalks, no street lamps.
我了解到，当各州在20世纪20年代和30年代建设公路系统时，他们把公路穿过保留地而不是绕过它们，因为如果它们穿过保留地，联邦政府就得买单。较少原住民拥有汽车，所以他们更有可能走在这些道路上。他们死在了没有路肩、没有路灯的地方。
In Montana, Native pedestrians make up more than half of hit and run fatalities, even though they're just 8% of the population. And what happens to the drivers? I scoured Montana newspapers and court records trying to figure out which cases got prosecuted.
在蒙大拿州，原住民行人占肇事逃逸死亡人数的一半以上，尽管他们仅占人口的8%。司机们怎么样了？我查阅了蒙大拿州的报纸和法庭记录，试图找出哪些案件得到了起诉。
I calculated that between 2011 and 2022, in cases where the victim was Native, it was much less likely for the drivers to be found. And when they were found, their sentences were much lighter. During that period, the drivers who killed Native pedestrians in Montana, if you added up all their sentences, it was a total of 51 years. Those who killed non-Native pedestrians, 265 years.
我计算出，在2011年至2022年间，受害者为原住民的案件中，司机被找到的可能性要小得多。而且即使找到了，他们的刑期也要轻得多。在此期间，杀害原住民行人的司机，如果将他们所有的刑期加起来，总共只有51年。而杀害非原住民行人的司机，刑期总共为265年。
Carissa and Kevin feared their case could end the same way that Tricia's and Bonnie's did-- with no one charged, even though law enforcement had found the drivers. They had a new goal-- get Sunny White arrested. Their strategy was public pressure. They would bring attention to Mika's case, and also to Bonnie and Tricia's kids' cases, since police had stopped investigating.
Carissa和Kevin担心他们的案子可能会像Tricia和Bonnie的那样结束——即使执法部门找到了司机，也没有人被起诉。他们有了一个新目标——让Sunny White被逮捕。他们的策略是公众压力。他们要让Mika的案子引起关注，也要让Bonnie和Tricia的孩子们的案子引起关注，因为警方已经停止了调查。
That night, they met with the mothers at their house. They came up with this idea. They'd do a four-day walk along Highway 93.
那天晚上，他们在家中与几位母亲见了面。他们想出了这个主意。他们要在93号高速公路上进行为期四天的步行。
Mika matters!
Mika很重要！
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Meena matters!
Meena matters!
Mika很重要！
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Aiden matters!
Aiden很重要！
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: They ended the walk on the steps of the Lake County courthouse. The march was all over local and national media. Kevin's a mailman and remembers how excited people on the reservation were when he delivered the state's biggest newspaper with Mika's face on the front page. Carissa created a Facebook group called Mika Matters and quickly collected over 1,000 followers. She started getting invitations to speak at big events, like at the grandstand for the Missoula County Fair.
步行在莱克县法院的台阶前结束。游行登上了所有当地和全国媒体的头条。Kevin是个邮差，他记得当他在州里最大的报纸上投递印有Mika照片的头版时，保留地上的人们有多激动。Carissa创建了一个名为“Mika Matters”的Facebook群组，并很快收集了超过1000名关注者。她开始收到邀请在大型活动上发言，比如在米苏拉县博览会的看台上。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Imagine if this was your child.
想象一下如果是你的孩子。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: There's this one video that Carissa shared with the media that blew up. It's of Mika. She's in their laundry room with a ukulele, singing a parody she wrote of Vance Joy's "Riptide."
Carissa与媒体分享过一个疯传的视频。那是Mika。她在洗衣房拿着一把尤克里里，唱着她改编的Vance Joy的《Riptide》。
(SINGING) I was scared of rez dogs in the wild
（演唱）我害怕野外的保留地流浪狗
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: She's singing, "I was scared of rez dogs in the wild. I was scared of drunk drivers and catching head lice."
她在唱，“我害怕野外的保留地流浪狗。我害怕酒驾司机，也害怕被传染头虱。”
(SINGING) I was scared of drunk drivers and catching head lice
（演唱）我害怕酒驾司机，也害怕被传染头虱
So all my cousins are brown
所以我的堂亲们都是棕色的
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: It's clever, funny. She never wanted to make the video, but when she played the song for Kevin, he begged her to let him film it.
这首歌很聪明、很有趣。她本不想拍这个视频，但当她把这首歌放给Kevin听时，他求她让他拍下来。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Was there an aspect of Mika's case that felt to you, like, oh, this has the potential to become big?
Mika的案子有没有哪方面让你觉得，“哦，这有成为大新闻的潜力”？
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Oh, yes. I believe it was because of the woman that hit her and her children's names.
哦，是的。我相信是因为那个撞她的女人以及她孩子们名字的缘故。
And the contrast of them with Mika-- like, Sunny, who appears to be a hateful person, or whatever, and then Mika, who's this hippie child, or whatever, that loves everybody and all that.
以及他们与Mika形成的对比——Sunny看起来是一个充满仇恨的人，等等；而Mika，是一个嬉皮士女孩，爱每个人等等。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Yeah, did it ever feel to you-- you're like, oh, this is sort of, like, the perfect victim and perfect villain narrative?
是的，你有没有觉得，“哦，这是一种完美的受害者和完美的恶棍叙事”？
Right. Yeah, Americans are dumb like that. They need the big villain and the kind, sweet-hearted victim, or whatever. So it's, like, you're twisted, you know? It's, like, one hand, it's really sad. And you think of all the other people that no one cares about. It's, like, because Mika is this young, beautiful, talented woman, people care about her.
对。是的，美国人就是那么蠢。他们需要一个大恶棍和一个善良、甜心的受害者。所以这很扭曲，你知道吗？一方面，这真的很悲伤。你会想到其他那些没人关心的人。因为Mika是这样一个年轻、漂亮、有才华的女性，人们才关心她。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: This perfect, dumb American narrative of victim and villain, innocent and guilty, Kevin and Carissa realized that Mika's could be the case that got people to care about all these hit and runs. And they decided Carissa would be the public face of their movement. She comes from a politically active family. Her dad was a state legislator and a tribal councilman.
这种完美的、愚蠢的美国式受害者与恶棍、无辜与有罪的叙事，Kevin和Carissa意识到，Mika的案子可能是让人关注所有这些肇事逃逸案的契机。他们决定Carissa将成为他们运动的公众形象。她来自一个积极参与政治的家庭。她的父亲曾是州议员和部落议员。
Kevin told me he felt a little cynical about all the public events Carissa was having to do. He didn't know of any white families who had to make a spectacle of their kids' cases to get justice. But he wanted to support Carissa and went to her events.
Kevin告诉我，对于Carissa不得不做的所有公开活动，他感到有点愤世嫉俗。他不知道有哪个白人家庭必须要把孩子的案件闹得沸沸扬扬才能获得正义。但他想支持Carissa，并参加了她的活动。
We're definitely yin and yang. Like, if it was just me, I'm going to be-- no one's going to like me. No one's going to talk to me. I'm going to piss everyone off. And it's-- I'm not going to get anything accomplished by myself. Whereas Carissa is the complete opposite. Everyone is going to want to talk to her. Everyone likes her, you know?
我们绝对是阴和阳。如果只有我一个人，没有人会喜欢我。没有人会跟我说话。我会惹恼所有人。我自己什么也做不成。而Carissa正好相反。每个人都想和她说话。每个人都喜欢她，你知道吗？
So I think it's nice to sneak in a couple right hooks, or whatever, that maybe knock some sense into some people without them even realizing it. And then she's going to be able to make it so everyone isn't just seeing this angry, Debbie Downer-type dude that hates everything.
所以我认为偷偷出几记右勾拳什么的挺好的，可能会让一些人清醒过来，而他们甚至都没意识到。然后她就能让大家看到的不是这样一个愤怒的、讨厌一切的“黛比”式家伙。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Yeah, I'm really struck by that. That's, like--
是的，我对此印象深刻。那是——
It makes for a very difficult relationship, though, because you never really agree on anything. So it's, like, she accepts that I'm wrong, and I accept that she's wrong, in our own minds. You know what I mean? And we're starting to learn that neither one of us are really wrong.
但这让关系变得非常困难，因为你们从不同意任何事情。就像，她接受我错了，而我接受她错了，在我们自己的心里。你知道我的意思吗？我们开始明白，我们谁也没有真正错。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: What's going through your head, Carissa?
Carissa，你在想什么？
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: I just-- I don't know. I appreciate my husband so much (CHUCKLING) for his truth and his fearlessness, that he's just going to come out and say whatever. That's how we're a good team, is that we are able to cover all sides of it.
我不知道。我非常感谢我的丈夫（轻笑），感谢他的诚实和无畏，他总是敢于说出任何想法。我们之所以是一个好团队，是因为我们能够涵盖所有的方面。
Coming up, Sierra talks to the county prosecutor about what the hell with not charging and arresting Sunny White. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
稍后，Sierra将与县检察官交谈，询问关于为什么不起诉和逮捕Sunny White。稍后，我们节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, How to Tell a Dumb American Story. Sierra Crane Murdoch picks up where she left off.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“如何讲述一个愚蠢的美国故事”。Sierra Crane Murdoch接着讲述刚才的内容。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: The prosecutor for Lake County is James Lapotka. His jurisdiction is basically the entire Flathead reservation. He's from Wisconsin, but has worked for Lake County for most of his career. He's white, in his early 40s, smiley. He looks like a Boy Scout. Mika's case had drawn more media attention than any other case he'd worked on because of Carissa's organizing.
莱克县的检察官是James Lapotka。他的管辖范围基本覆盖了整个弗拉特黑德保留地。他来自威斯康星州，但在莱克县工作了职业生涯的大部分时间。他是白人，40岁出头，总是微笑。他看起来像个童子军。由于Carissa的组织，Mika的案件吸引了比他处理过的任何其他案件更多的媒体关注。
Let me try to dig this out-- 100 pages of comments from Facebook, articles from The New York Times. I got a text message from somebody who is not my friend on Facebook, saying, "You racist piece of shit. You will not try that stupid white supremacist bitch because she's white. You're garbage."
让我试着挖出来——100页的Facebook评论，纽约时报的文章。我收到了一条来自不是我Facebook好友的人发来的短信，上面写着：“你这个种族主义的垃圾。你不会去起诉那个愚蠢的白人至上主义婊子，因为她是白人。你简直是垃圾。”
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: It was annoying. But the attention also got him more resources from the FBI and the state. He met with Carissa and Kevin briefly a couple of times in the months after Mika died.
这很烦人。但这种关注也让他从FBI和州政府那里获得了更多资源。在Mika去世后的几个月里，他曾简短地会见了Carissa和Kevin几次。
I tried to assure them, like, I'm not a white supremacist covering up a homicide for my white supremacist friend. Like, that's not what this is about. And I think I got some of that through to them. But I think that they were also a little righteously upset that we weren't moving faster.
我试图向他们保证，我不是一个为白人至上主义朋友掩盖谋杀案的白人至上主义者。这不是关于那个的。我想我让一部分话传达到他们那里了。但我也认为他们对于我们行动不够快而感到义愤填膺。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: He acknowledged that Montana Highway Patrol had made mistakes that slowed down the investigation. He had to let Sunny White out of jail because investigators hadn't collected enough evidence to charge her. He also needed Sunny's blood test results to prove she had been intoxicated, but orders at the Montana Crime Lab were backed up.
他承认蒙大拿州公路巡警犯了错误，延缓了调查。他不得不让Sunny White离开监狱，因为调查人员收集的证据不足以起诉她。他还需要Sunny的血液检测结果来证明她喝醉了，但蒙大拿州犯罪实验室的积压订单太多。
He told me he never found anything that proved Sunny hit Mika because she was Native. He couldn't verify the rumor that Sunny had come to the reservation to kill an Indian, so he couldn't charge her with a hate crime. I got the sense that he wanted to do a good job for Mika's family. The first time we met, I was struck by his genuine warmth whenever he talked about Mika.
他告诉我，他从未找到任何证据证明Sunny是因为Mika是原住民而撞了她。他无法证实Sunny来到保留地是为了杀一个印第安人的传言，所以他不能以仇恨犯罪起诉她。我感觉到他想为Mika的家庭做好工作。我们第一次见面时，每当他谈到Mika，他的真诚温暖让我印象深刻。
She was a delightful kid.
她是个令人愉快的孩子。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Really?
真的吗？
You can tell that just by looking through her phone.
你只要翻翻她的手机就能看出来。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: What were some of the-- like, do you remember anything in particular that really endeared you to her?
你还记得有什么特别让你对她产生好感的事情吗？
She did a lot of videos and a lot of pictures of her, a lot of selfies. They were rather innocent, kind of, like, little kid. It made me like Mika a lot more.
她拍了很多视频和照片，很多自拍。它们相当天真，就像小孩子一样。这让我更喜欢Mika了。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: It was sweet, but also it made me wonder-- if he didn't have those photos of Mika, would he like her? Would he have felt as motivated to work on her case? He didn't talk this way about Bonnie and Tricia's kids, Maureen and Aiden. He called what happened to them tragic, but he also said he didn't think a jury would have much sympathy for them. He said they made choices that put themselves at risk.
这很感人，但也让我好奇——如果他没有那些Mika的照片，他会喜欢她吗？他会有动力去处理她的案子吗？他谈论Bonnie和Tricia的孩子Maureen和Aiden时不是这种态度。他称他们遭遇的事情是悲剧，但也表示他认为陪审团不会对他们有多少同情心。他说他们做出的选择让自己处于危险之中。
Highway Patrol concluded that Aiden was lying in the road when he was hit. He'd sent text messages to friends suggesting he was suicidal. And someone reported Maureena stumbling, intoxicated, just before she was killed. Lapotka told me he didn't see any way he could win a trial in either case.
公路巡警得出结论，Aiden在被撞时正躺在路上。他曾给朋友发短信暗示他有自杀倾向。还有人报告说Maureena在被杀前喝醉了酒，跌跌撞撞。Lapotka告诉我，他看不出在任何一起案件中他能赢得审判。
But his explanations left out some key details, like the fact that the driver who killed Maureena was intoxicated, too, or that in Aiden's evidence file, the coroner said that Aiden's injuries indicated that he'd been standing when he got hit, not lying down. All of this was the sort of reasoning that caused so much agony for Tricia and Bonnie, the feeling that law enforcement assumed their kids were responsible for their own deaths.
但他解释中遗漏了一些关键细节，比如撞死Maureena的司机也喝醉了酒，或者在Aiden的证据文件中，法医说Aiden的伤情表明他在被撞时是站着的，而不是躺着的。所有这些推理都是让Tricia和Bonnie感到极其痛苦的原因，那种执法部门假定他们的孩子应对自己死亡负责的感觉。
Six months after Mika was killed, in October of 2023, Lapotka was finally close to filing charges against Sunny White. He invited Carissa and Kevin into his office to hear about the evidence he had compiled against her.
Mika去世六个月后，在2023年10月，Lapotka终于准备对Sunny White提起指控。他邀请Carissa和Kevin到办公室听取他收集到的针对她的证据。
I was kind of excited. I'm like, hey guys, look, I-- look, we did it! Look, I have all this stuff. This is what we've got. Let me show you the whole thing. And then this is the timeline and what to expect. That's how I felt. That meeting was-- what that meeting was for.
我当时还有点兴奋。我心想，嘿，伙计们，看，我……看，我们做到了！看，我有这些东西。这就是我们拥有的。让我给你们展示全貌。然后这是时间表以及预期情况。那就是我感觉到的。那是那次会议的目的。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: That's not how Carissa and Kevin felt about the meeting. One of the pieces of evidence he showed them was body cam footage from the day Mika was killed, just hours after Sunny hit her. Her SUV, a Cadillac Escalade, had broken down in a church parking lot. It was missing the passenger side mirror. Police had found the mirror not far from Mika's body. In the video, the officer talks to Sunny outside her car. Her two young kids are in the back.
那不是Carissa和Kevin对那次会议的感觉。他给他们看的一份证据是Mika遇害当天，就在Sunny撞倒她几小时后的随身摄像头录像。她的SUV，一辆凯迪拉克Escalade，在教堂停车场抛锚了。它丢了乘客侧的后视镜。警察在离Mika尸体不远处发现了这个后视镜。在视频中，警官在Sunny的车外与她交谈。她的两个年幼的孩子在后面。
And she's totally just manipulating the shit out of the sheriff, or deputy. She's crying and-- oh, my gosh, I don't know what's happening. And that sheriff is like, oh, it's-- letting her smoke cigarettes. Like--
她完全是在操控治安官或副手。她在那儿哭，哦天哪，我不知道发生了什么。那个治安官就像，哦，让她抽烟。就像——
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: She's not contained--
她没有被控制——
I'm thinking, like--
我心想，就像——
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: --not handcuffed.
——没戴手铐。
--if this was a Native woman, she would be stuffed and cuffed immediately.
如果这是一个原住民女性，她会立刻被扣上并带走。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: I saw this video. The deputy does actually cuff Sunny for a few minutes. He tells her she didn't hit a deer-- she hit a person. And she starts crying, asks if she's going to prison forever. Not forever, he says. But then he takes the cuffs off. Her brother-in-law had shown up to pick up her kids. Sunny starts moving car seats and bags into his truck.
我看到了这段视频。副手确实给Sunny戴了几分钟手铐。他告诉她她撞到的不是鹿——而是人。她开始哭，问她是否会永远坐牢。他说不会永远。但后来他把手铐取了下来。她的姐夫出现了，要把她的孩子们接走。Sunny开始把儿童座椅和包搬进他的卡车。
I'm like, Lapotka, what the hell? This is a potential crime scene, and he's letting her move items from the vehicle.
我心想，Lapotka，搞什么鬼？这是一个潜在的犯罪现场，他竟然让她从车里搬走物品。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: I was quiet that whole thing. I didn't say one thing because I was mad. Is everyone this dumb [LAUGHS] in this world that are in these positions of power? And we're telling them what they need to look for or do, how to do their-- I don't know. Me and Kevin's looking at each other, and we're like, oh, my god. It's crazy, you know? I just can't believe it, sometimes.
我整个过程中都很安静。我什么都没说，因为我很生气。在这个世界掌握权力位置的人都这么蠢吗？（笑）我们在告诉他们需要寻找或做什么，怎么做他们的——我不知道。我和Kevin面面相觑，心想，我的天哪。这简直疯了，你知道吗？我有时简直不敢相信。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Lapotka thinks that Sunny's phone was probably in one of those bags. Highway Patrol never found it. That slowed down the investigation. He suspects there were drugs and paraphernalia in those bags, too. Her toxicology came back positive for methamphetamine and fentanyl.
Lapotka认为Sunny的手机可能在其中一个包里。公路巡警从未找到它。那延缓了调查。他怀疑那些包里还有毒品和吸毒工具。她的毒理学报告显示甲基苯丙胺和芬太尼呈阳性。
I will readily acknowledge that in hindsight, we should have not let her remove evidence from the vehicle while we're doing an investigation. That should not have happened.
我愿意承认，事后看来，我们在进行调查时确实不应该让她从车里移走证据。那是不应该发生的。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: But he also told me one of the kids was in a diaper and needed clothes, so he could see why the officer let Sunny move some bags. I kept noticing this dynamic whenever I asked Lapotka about a mistake law enforcement made. He'd readily acknowledge it, but then he also always had an explanation that assumed the officers had good intentions.
但他同时也告诉我其中一个孩子穿着尿布，需要衣服，所以他能理解为什么警官让Sunny搬走一些包。每当我问Lapotka关于执法部门犯下的错误时，我总是注意到这种动态。他会爽快地承认，但随后他总是会给出一个假设警官动机良好的解释。
Like, when I asked him about Bieber taking Mika's phone, he said, yeah, his bedside manner sucked. But Bieber is also a good guy, and he needed her phone to quickly rule out suicide. If she had been suicidal, it could cause problems for them at trial.
就像当我问他关于Bieber拿走Mika手机的事时，他说，是的，他的态度太糟糕了。但Bieber也是个好人，他拿走手机是为了快速排除自杀的可能性。如果她是自杀的，这可能会在审判时给他们造成麻烦。
Montana Highway Patrol finally arrested Sunny White just a few days after Lapotka showed Carissa and Kevin the body cam footage. She was charged with negligent vehicular homicide, leaving the scene, drug possession, and child endangerment. Lapotka called Carissa to tell her the news.
蒙大拿州公路巡警在Lapotka给Carissa和Kevin看过随身摄像头录像几天后，终于逮捕了Sunny White。她被控过失车辆杀人、离开现场、非法持有毒品和危害儿童。Lapotka打电话告诉Carissa这个消息。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: I couldn't believe that it was happening.
我简直不敢相信这正在发生。
Yeah, it was shocking if you just think about the fact that it took us seven months to get to square one.
是的，如果你想到我们花了七个月才回到起点，这确实令人震惊。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Would you have brought charges without the amount of media attention that Kevin and Carissa brought to this case?
如果没有Kevin和Carissa对这个案件带来的媒体关注量，你会提起指控吗？
Yes. It might have taken a little longer, and it might not have been as good. I think eventually, we would have brought charges. Honestly, the amount of media attention made it easier for me to get help from people. So our case ended up being better because of what they did, but they didn't have to do that to get my attention.
会。这可能需要更长一点时间，可能也不会有那么好。我认为最终我们会提起指控。老实说，媒体关注量的确让我更容易从别人那里获得帮助。所以我们的案子因为他们所做的而变得更好，但他们不需要那样做才能得到我的关注。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Sunny White pleaded not guilty and posted bond immediately-- $100,000. I reached out to her for an interview and didn't hear back. Now that Sunny had been arrested, Kevin and Carissa had a new goal. They announced it to the media at a press conference outside the Lake County courthouse.
Sunny White做了无罪抗辩，并立即缴纳了保证金——10万美元。我联系她进行采访，没有收到回复。既然Sunny已经被捕，Kevin和Carissa有了新目标。他们在莱克县法院外的新闻发布会上向媒体宣布了这一点。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: I'm thankful that today finally happened, where Sunny White was read her charges. I don't want the judge and the county to take the easy way out, doing a plea bargain. I would like to see this go to trial.
我很感激今天终于发生了，Sunny White被宣读了指控。我不希望法官和县里走捷径进行辩诉交易。我希望看到此案进入审判程序。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: What did a trial mean to you? Like, what would a trial have given you?
审判对你意味着什么？就像，审判能给你什么？
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: I was thinking, yeah, plea bargain, that's the easy way out. That's keeping it hush-hush, sweeping it under the rug. That's cutting the media out and all that. You know what I mean? It's ending abruptly when we did all this. And looking at the bigger goal as, it would be trial, and everything would be laid out and all that, you know? That's what I visualized.
我在想，辩诉交易，那是逃避责任的捷径。那是保持低调，掩盖事实。那是切断媒体等等。你知道我的意思吗？当我们做了这么多努力，一切却戛然而止。而从大目标来看，审判意味着一切都会被摆在台面上，你知道吗？那才是我预想的。
Yeah, if it was to go to trial, Lapotka and Lake County would have had, and the Montana Highway Patrol would have had to present it to the world exactly how they investigated this case. Any halfway decent attorney would have been able to pick apart their so-called investigation and evidence.
是的，如果进入审判，Lapotka和莱克县，以及蒙大拿州公路巡警将不得不向全世界展示他们到底是如何调查这个案子的。任何一个称职的律师都能拆解他们所谓的调查和证据。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Yeah, that's so interesting. Like, would you say you wanted the state to lose?
是的，那太有趣了。你是说你希望州政府输吗？
I mean, absolutely, which kind of probably sounds ridiculous. So I mean, Mika is gone. There's nothing that's going to ever bring her back. So I would sacrifice Mika's personal justice for a big-picture justice. You know what I mean? That would be a very easy sacrifice for me, personally.
我的意思是，绝对是的，这听起来可能很荒谬。所以我的意思是，Mika已经走了。没有什么能让她回来。所以我愿意为了一个大局的正义牺牲Mika的个人正义。你知道我的意思吗？对我个人而言，那将是一个非常简单的牺牲。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Kevin kept thinking about this one time, shortly before Mika was killed. He was in the kitchen.
Kevin一直在回想Mika遇害前不久的那次。他在厨房里。
I came in the house to eat something, and Mika was in her room. And she comes bolting out, like, hey, bro, if someone murked me, you'd forgive them, right? And I just remember, like, what are you talking about, weirdo? And she's like, well, you would, right? And I was like, I don't know. Would you want me to? She said, well, yeah. And I was like, well, then, yeah, I guess.
我进屋想吃点东西，Mika在她的房间里。她冲出来说，“嘿，兄弟，如果有人干掉了我，你会原谅他们，对吧？”我只记得，心想，你在说什么啊，怪胎？她说，“嗯，你会的，对吧？”我说，“我不知道。你想让我原谅吗？”她说，“嗯，是的。”我说，“好吧，那么，是的，我想我会。”
To me, it was like some dumb thing she would say. But and then later, she's dead by the hands of someone else. And I was, like-- it tripped me out, you know? I had to forgive that-- Sunny White right away. And I did, you know?
对我来说，这就像她会说的某种蠢话。但后来，她死在了别人的手中。我心想——这让我震惊，你知道吗？我必须立刻原谅Sunny White。我也确实原谅了，你知道吗？
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Forgiving Sunny was easier than he thought. He wasn't angry at her. He was angry at Montana and Lake County for how they handled this case, for how they handled Bonnie's and Tricia's cases, too. It was the state's fault that a driver could leave a Native pedestrian to die on the side of the road and think she'd get away with it.
原谅Sunny比他想象的要容易。他不生她的气。他生蒙大拿州和莱克县的气，气他们处理这个案子的方式，也气他们处理Bonnie和Tricia案子的方式。国家有错，因为一个司机可以在路边让原住民行人死去，并以为自己能逃脱惩罚。
A trial date was set for December 2024. Lapotka invited Carissa and Kevin to his office for another meeting. He had some good news. The case had become so high-profile that the Montana Attorney General's Office sent in one of its best trial attorneys, Thorin Geist. And he'd gotten Mika's blood alcohol content excluded from trial. This was a big win for Carissa and Kevin. Mika had been over the legal limit for walking on the road. But within a couple of minutes, the real point of this meeting became clear.
审判日期定在2024年12月。Lapotka邀请Carissa和Kevin到办公室进行另一次会议。他带来了一些好消息。这个案子已经变得如此受瞩目，以至于蒙大拿州总检察长办公室派出了他们最优秀的审判律师之一，Thorin Geist。而且他已经把Mika的血液酒精浓度排除在审判之外了。这对Carissa和Kevin来说是一个巨大的胜利。Mika当时的酒精含量确实超过了法律规定的路边行走标准。但在几分钟内，这次会议的真正目的变得清晰起来。
Sunny's attorney came to us a couple of weeks back and wanted to talk about what we think would be a fair resolution to this case, but we wanted to consult with you before we made any formal offer.
Sunny的律师几周前找到我们，想谈谈我们认为这个案子什么结果是公平的，但我们在做出任何正式提议之前想先咨询你们。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: So that's a plea bargain, right?
所以那是辩诉交易，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: OK.
好的。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: A plea bargain. Carissa is caught off guard. She thought she'd made it clear to Lapotka that they wanted a trial. Lapotka says he is ready to go to trial, but he also wants to offer a plea because anything can happen at a trial. They could lose the whole thing on one jury member.
辩诉交易。Carissa措手不及。她以为她已经向Lapotka明确表示过他们想要审判。Lapotka说他准备好进行审判了，但他也想提供一份认罪协议，因为审判中什么都可能发生。他们可能因为一个陪审团成员而全盘皆输。
And even if they did win, Sunny would likely file an appeal. It could take years to work its way through the courts. Lapotka is in this dance with the family. He doesn't have to do what the family says, but he has an incentive to get them on his side, because if the family doesn't want a plea bargain, the judge could reject it. So Lapotka keeps pressuring them to consider a plea deal, but then he also keeps trying to make it seem like he's not.
而且即使他们赢了，Sunny很可能会提出上诉。那可能需要数年时间才能走完法律程序。Lapotka正在与这个家庭跳舞。他不一定非要按照家人的要求做，但他有动力让他们站在他这一边，因为如果家人不想要辩诉交易，法官可能会拒绝它。所以Lapotka一直给他们施加压力考虑认罪协议，但同时他又一直试图让事情看起来不是那样。
We are not afraid. I don't want you to think we're just trying to settle this so we can go home.
我们并不害怕。我不想让你们以为我们只是想解决这个问题以便回家。
To me, this is an opportunity to make a change. I don't know. That's all--
对我来说，这是一个做出改变的机会。我不知道。这就是全部——
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: The state prosecutor, Thorin Geist, says he'd like to make a plea offer tomorrow. He needs them to think about numbers. If Sunny pleads guilty to the first two counts, vehicular homicide and leaving the scene, that gives them up to 40 years in prison. But she wouldn't serve all of the years she's sentenced to. They'd have to offer to suspend some of that time.
州检察官Thorin Geist说他明天想提出认罪提议。他需要他们考虑数字。如果Sunny对前两项指控（车辆杀人罪和离开现场罪）认罪，这可以让他们要求最高40年的刑期。但她不会服完她被判的所有年份。他们必须提议缓刑部分时间。
The question then becomes this-- what does justice look like to this family?
问题就变成了——在这个家庭眼中正义是什么样子的？
To me, the whole point of this trial would be to discourage future freakin' homicides. And so my concern is-- and I know that Mika would feel the same way-- is these other Aryan nations, we've had an influx of these groups moving here recently. They need to see these hard numbers. So there's got to be-- 40 years is like, oh, shit, that's my life. My life is essentially done.
对我来说，审判的全部意义在于遏制未来该死的杀人案。所以我担心的是——我知道Mika也会有同样的感觉——那些其他的雅利安国（Aryan Nations）成员，我们最近涌入了这些团体的成员。他们需要看到这些硬性的数字。所以必须有——40年就像是，“哦，天哪，那就是我的一生。”我的人生基本上结束了。
So what do you think is appropriate?
那么你们觉得多少合适？
40 years.
40年。
40 straight?
40年全刑期？
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Kevin told me his strategy at this point was to offer Sunny an unrealistic deal so trial would be her only option. Lapotka turns to Carissa.
Kevin告诉我他当时的策略是给Sunny提供一个不现实的交易，这样审判将是她唯一的选择。Lapotka转向Carissa。
Carissa, you're awful quiet over there. You were just starting to say something.
Carissa，你安静得可怕。你刚才开始要说什么。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: No, I'm just thinking.
不，我只是在想。
Sorry, go ahead.
抱歉，请继续。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: When would you like us to tell you what terms? I mean, today?
你想让我们什么时候告诉你什么条款？我的意思是，今天吗？
If we could get--
如果我们能得到——
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Oh, it is. Yeah. Gosh.
哦，是这样。是的。天哪。
--something from you by Tuesday, that would help us out a lot.
——周二之前得到你们的回复，那会对我们有很大帮助。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: And if sooner, we'll--
如果更早的话，我们会——
Yeah.
是的。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: --yeah, we'll get a hold of you.
——我们会联系你的。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Up until this meeting, Kevin and Carissa had presented a united front, even when they disagreed. But this question of whether to keep pushing for trial or to sign off on a plea deal revealed a fracture between them. They didn't discuss it any more on the way home. Kevin wanted a trial.
在这次会议之前，Kevin和Carissa表现出团结一致的阵线，即使他们不同意。但关于是否继续推进审判还是签署认罪协议的问题，揭示了他们之间的裂痕。在回家的路上他们没再讨论。Kevin想要审判。
Carissa understood, but she also understood that prosecutors were going to offer a plea, no matter what. She felt caught between aligning with her husband and showing willingness to work with the state so they didn't cut her out. She didn't want to lose what little control she had.
Carissa理解，但她也明白，无论如何检察官都会提供认罪协议。她感到夹在与丈夫保持一致和表现出与州政府合作的意愿之间，以免他们把她排除在外。她不想失去她仅存的那点控制权。
So when Lapotka called her a few days later to ask for a number, she told him 40 years with 20 suspended. I tried calling Kevin after to see how he felt. He didn't pick up. Instead, I got a call from Carissa. She sounded worried that I'd heard they had a disagreement.
所以当Lapotka几天后打电话让她给个数字时，她说40年，其中20年缓刑。我后来试着打电话给Kevin看他感觉如何。他没接。相反，我接到了Carissa的电话。她听起来很担心我听到他们有分歧。
A week passed. Sunny still hadn't accepted the plea deal, which was about to expire. Carissa and Kevin headed to court. They sat in the front row. I sat behind them, waiting for their case to come up.
一周过去了。Sunny仍然没有接受认罪协议，协议即将到期。Carissa和Kevin去了法庭。他们坐在第一排。我坐在他们后面，等着他们的案子被提上议程。
Suddenly, Lapotka approached. He leaned over to whisper in Carissa's ear. Then she leaned over and whispered to Kevin. They followed Lapotka out of the courtroom. When they returned a few minutes later, I couldn't read their faces. Carissa whispered to her dad.
突然，Lapotka走近了。他弯下腰在Carissa耳边低语。然后她弯下腰在Kevin耳边低语。他们跟着Lapotka走出了法庭。几分钟后他们回来时，我读不出他们的表情。Carissa对她父亲耳语了几句。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: I just want it to be over.
我只是想让它结束。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: The judge called up their case.
法官传唤了他们的案子。
OK, so now we'll go to DC 23-344, State of Montana versus Sunny Catherine White.
好的，现在我们进行DC 23-344，蒙大拿州诉Sunny Catherine White案。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: The courtroom door opened again, and Sunny walked in.
法庭大门再次打开，Sunny走了进来。
I have just been handed a plea agreement. Is that correct?
我刚刚收到了一份认罪协议。是这样吗？
That is correct, Your Honor. And I'm sorry for our tardiness.
正是如此，法官阁下。很抱歉我们迟到了。
Oh, it's OK. All right, so--
哦，没关系。好吧，那么——
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: I noticed that Sunny had a new tattoo on her forehead, over her right brow. It said "Aryan" in blue cursive.
我注意到Sunny前额、右眉上方有一个新纹身。上面用蓝色连体字写着“Aryan”。
So Ms. White, with your rights in mind, are you ready to enter into a plea based on the plea agreement?
那么White女士，在意识到你的权利的情况下，你准备好根据认罪协议进行认罪了吗？
Yes.
是的。
As to counts one and two, how do you plead?
关于第一项和第二项指控，你如何抗辩？
Guilty, Your Honor.
认罪，法官阁下。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Sunny's defense attorney read the facts she was pleading guilty to.
Sunny的辩护律师宣读了她认罪的事实。
Sunny, as to count one, on or about March 31 of 2023, did you negligently cause the death of Mika Westwolf while operating a motor vehicle while under the influence of drugs in Lake County, Montana?
Sunny，关于第一项指控，在2023年3月31日左右，你是否在蒙大拿州莱克县，在药物影响下操作机动车时过失杀害了Mika Westwolf？
Yes.
是的。
And you did not render aid or remain at the scene?
而且你没有提供援助或留在现场？
Yes.
是的。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Carissa started crying. She leaned into her dad.
Carissa开始哭泣。她靠在她父亲身上。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: [CRYING]
（哭泣）
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Carissa and Kevin didn't get a trial, but Carissa did get something she hadn't expected-- she heard Sunny White admit to killing their daughter.
Carissa和Kevin没有得到审判，但Carissa确实得到了她没预料到的东西——她听到了Sunny White承认杀害了他们的女儿。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: It was a huge, almost instantaneous weight off my shoulders. I just felt it gone. And that's part of what brought on the crying. I don't know. Something just clicked inside of me where I just felt like, finally, you know? She's admitting guilt.
那是一个巨大的，几乎瞬间从我肩上卸下的重担。我只觉得它消失了。这就是导致哭泣的部分原因。我不知道。我内心深处有什么东西被触动了，我只觉得，终于，你知道吗？她在承认有罪。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Of course, Kevin did not feel that way.
当然，Kevin没有那种感觉。
We just played right into their hand. It was the best-case scenario to get the family to be OK with a slap on the wrist. So I felt dirty.
我们正好落入了他们的圈套。让家人接受“打一巴掌给个甜枣”的结局是最好的方案。所以我感觉很脏。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Did you sense how Carissa felt?
你察觉到Carissa的感觉了吗？
I did feel her relief. I think that she was really trying to ignore my vibe, which-- and I totally understand. She deserves all the credit, and she's taken on the weight of this way more than I have.
我确实感觉到了她的解脱。我想她真的在试着忽略我的情绪，我完全理解。她值得所有赞誉，她承受的负担比我多得多。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Carissa had asked for 40 years with 20 suspended, but the plea offer Sunny agreed to was 30 years with 20 suspended. What this meant was that Sunny would spend a maximum of 10 years in prison. And she could still request parole and get out earlier.
Carissa曾要求40年刑期缓刑20年，但Sunny同意的认罪方案是30年缓刑20年。这意味着Sunny最多会在监狱里待10年。而且她仍然可以申请假释并提前出狱。
To prevent that, Carissa and Kevin could ask the judge for a parole restriction at Sunny's sentencing hearing, make it so that Sunny would have to stay in prison the full 10 years. That way, they wouldn't have to keep returning to court to make their case every time she applied for parole. Or they could try to get the judge to reject the plea deal and send it back to trial.
为了防止这种情况，Carissa和Kevin可以在Sunny的量刑听证会上请求法官加上假释限制，让Sunny必须在监狱里待满10年。这样，他们就不必每次她申请假释时都不断回到法庭上进行辩论。或者他们可以尝试让法官拒绝认罪协议，将其退回重新审判。
(SUBJECT) GEORGE HEAVY RUNNER: Yeah, let's put them in there.
是的，让我们把他们关进去。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Sunny's sentencing hearing was on a snowy morning this past February. Mika's family and supporters gathered in front of the Lake County courthouse to put up a red teepee. This was almost two years after Mika was killed. Carissa handed out Mika Matters T-shirts.
Sunny的量刑听证会在今年二月一个下雪的早晨举行。Mika的家人和支持者聚集在莱克县法院前搭起了一个红色的圆锥形帐篷。这离Mika被杀已经快两年了。Carissa分发了“Mika Matters”T恤。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: I got your shirts right here, guys.
我这有你们的T恤，伙计们。
This is my daughter, Lisa.
这是我的女儿Lisa。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Yeah, hey, Lisa. Thanks for coming.
是的，嘿，Lisa。谢谢你能来。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Kevin hadn't shown up yet, and Carissa kept looking around for him.
Kevin还没出现，Carissa不停地四处寻找他。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Just waiting for Kevin to bring the extension cords for the hot chocolate.
只是在等Kevin带热巧克力的延长线来。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: They'd been fighting. Kevin still didn't want the plea deal. He didn't want to endorse the state's narrative that they were getting justice. But Carissa was exhausted. She wanted it all to be over. She started venting to a friend.
他们一直在吵架。Kevin仍然不想要认罪协议。他不想背书州政府的叙事，认为他们得到了正义。但Carissa精疲力竭。她想让这一切都结束。她开始向一位朋友发泄。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: We haven't even been talking. I don't know if we're going to survive this, honestly. It's him. He can't handle what I'm doing, I guess. I don't know. It sucks. And to pull this shit, like, right before this? Selfish.
我们甚至都没怎么说话。老实说，我不知道我们能否挺过这一关。是他。我猜他受不了我做的事情。我不知道。这太糟糕了。而且就在这之前搞这一出？自私。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Kevin still hadn't arrived when the sentencing hearing was about to start.
量刑听证会开始时Kevin还没到。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: I'd better get in. It's 8:53. But thank you for being here. I hope Kevin's not too late.
我最好进去了。8点53分了。但谢谢你们能来。我希望Kevin不会太晚。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: The room was packed, most of them here for Mika. Mika's young cousins were curled up on their puffy jackets on the floor. Finally, Kevin arrived-- dirty boots, jeans, hoodie.
房间里挤满了人，大部分是为了Mika来的。Mika年幼的堂亲们蜷缩在地板上厚厚的夹克上。终于，Kevin到了——脏靴子、牛仔裤、连帽衫。
A screen to the judge's right rotated through portraits of Mika and candid family photos. One by one, the judge called her relatives up to speak. They told stories about Mika. Her Great-Aunt Iris named eight of her own relatives who have been killed on roads in Montana. I got the sense of how relentless grief can be when new cases are opening before old ones even close. Finally, it was Kevin's turn.
法官右侧的屏幕轮流播放Mika的肖像和生活照。法官一个个点名让她的亲属上去发言。他们讲述了Mika的故事。她的姨婆Iris点出了八位死于蒙大拿州公路上的亲属。我体会到了当新案件在旧案结束前就开启时，那种无尽的悲伤。终于，轮到Kevin了。
Judge, the state calls Kevin Howard.
法官，州政府传唤Kevin Howard。
All right, Mr. Howard.
好的，Howard先生。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: He slumped onto the stand, hung his ballcap on his knee.
他瘫坐在证人席上，把球帽挂在膝盖上。
What would you like to say to the court here today?
你今天想对法庭说什么？
So as you've all heard, Mika was quite a special person. As a parent, typically, we teach our children. I think in my case, I learned a lot more from her than I taught her.
正如你们所听到的，Mika是一个相当特别的人。作为父母，通常我们教导孩子。我想在我的例子里，我从她身上学到的比教她的多得多。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: He told the story again of Mika in the kitchen, when she asked if he'd ever forgive a person who murdered her.
他再次讲述了Mika在厨房里的故事，当她问他是否会原谅谋杀她的人。
I have no choice but to honor her wishes and forgive Mrs. White for her heinous act. But growing up on this rez, I've lost other family members in similar ways that didn't receive justice. And so for that, I cannot forgive. And until there's a change that's made, I hold Lake County responsible. I hold this court responsible.
我别无选择，只能尊重她的愿望，原谅White夫人那令人发指的行为。但在这个保留地上长大，我以同样的方式失去了其他家人，他们却没有得到正义。所以对于这一点，我无法原谅。在做出改变之前，我追究莱克县的责任。我追究这个法庭的责任。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: He brought up what Montana Highway Patrol did to Bonnie after her daughter Maureena was killed.
他提到了蒙大拿州公路巡警在Bonnie的女儿Maureena被杀后对她做的事情。
The same lead investigator of the Highway Patrol, Wayne Bieber, stonewalled Meena's mom and basically intimidated her to just back down and let things go. So we are not receiving justice today. Even though we're all here thinking we are, you guys are pacifying us in an effort to continue about your discriminatory practices. She will be granted parole. She's a white lady with two young children. Why wouldn't she? That's the way the system works.
公路巡警的首席调查员Wayne Bieber，封锁了Mika妈妈的消息，基本上恐吓她退缩，让事情随它去。所以我们今天没有得到正义。尽管我们都在这里以为我们得到了，你们在安抚我们，以便继续你们的歧视性做法。她会被批准假释。她是一个有两个年幼孩子的白人女性。为什么不会呢？这就是系统的运作方式。
All right, well, you don't-- I know everything that you're saying is completely valid. I totally understand where you're coming from, but you don't actually-- you don't know what this court is going to sentence her to yet.
好吧，嗯，你不需要——我知道你说的每一句话都是完全有效的。我完全理解你的立场，但你其实——你还不知道这个法庭会判她多少年。
Thank you, Your Honor. And I hope that it's not the plea deal. I hope that we go to trial and we see exactly how this investigation took place, how we, as a family, were forced to investigate our own daughter's death. What kind of nonsense is that? You guys need to do better. I mean, how many families do you know personally, James, that have not received justice?
谢谢你，法官阁下。我希望那不是认罪协议。我希望我们进入审判程序，看看这个调查到底是怎么进行的，我们作为一个家庭是如何被迫调查自己女儿的死因的。那是什么鬼话？你们需要做得更好。我的意思是，James，你个人认识多少没有得到正义的家庭？
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: He means James Lapotka, the county prosecutor.
他是指县检察官James Lapotka。
Sorry, he can't answer you.
抱歉，他没法回答你。
I'm done. Yeah. Thank you, Your Honor.
我说完了。是的。谢谢你，法官阁下。
And you don't agree with the plea agreement?
你不赞同认罪协议？
Absolutely not.
绝对不。
You would have wanted this to go to trial?
你本来希望此案进入审判程序？
Absolutely. And not to-- just to expose the-- the--
绝对。而且不仅仅是为了——揭露——
The treatment that you went through--
你所经历的对待——
--inadequate investigation.
——调查不充分。
And it seems that you went through-- the treatment that you were subjected to is horrible. And I'm so sorry for that.
而且看起来你所遭受的对待——确实很可怕。对此我深表歉意。
Yet nothing is being done.
然而什么都没做。
And I think that it's powerful for you to come here today, though, to talk about this. And we need to hear from folks like you who have been treated badly. And so thank you for coming and saying all of that. All right. Thank you--
而且我认为你今天能到这里来谈论这个问题很有力量。我们需要听听像你这样受到不公正对待的人的声音。所以谢谢你来这里说这些。好的。谢谢——
You can make the change, Your Honor. You can start the change.
法官阁下，你可以做出改变。你可以开启改变。
All right. Well, thank you very much. Anything else you'd like to add?
好的。嗯，非常感谢。你还有什么想补充的吗？
No.
没有。
OK. You may step down.
好的。你可以下去了。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: This is the first time the judge has heard that Mika's family doesn't like the plea deal. I wondered if the judge might actually reject the plea and send the whole case back to trial. But then Carissa took the stand.
这是法官第一次听到Mika的家人不喜欢这份认罪协议。我很好奇法官是否真的会拒绝认罪协议并将整个案件退回审判。但随后Carissa站上了证人席。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Hello, everyone. [SIGHS] Thank you for being here.
大家好。（叹气）谢谢你们来这里。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: She pulled out a crumpled sheet from a yellow legal pad.
她拿出了一张从黄色法律便签本上撕下的皱巴巴的纸。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: I had to speak up, as hard as it was, when all I wanted to do was stay in bed and do nothing and just cry. But I couldn't because that's not who I am. And that is not the people that I come from. And that's not the values that I instilled in my daughter.
我必须站出来，尽管这很艰难，当我只想待在床上什么也不做，只是哭泣的时候。但我不能，因为那不是我。那也不是我来自的人群。那也不是我灌输给我女儿的价值观。
And I had to do what I had to do, as hard as it was-- so hard. And this is what all these other families are up against, when you should just be able to grieve and trust the system, trust the law enforcement to have open communication with you and to trust that they're doing their job. And I didn't have that trust.
我必须做我该做的，尽管这很难——太难了。这就是所有其他家庭所面临的情况，当你本应能够哀悼并信任这个系统，信任执法部门会与你有公开沟通，并相信他们是在做他们的工作。但我没有那种信任。
And it's breaking our family. It's causing strain between me and my husband. And most families, parents that lose a child, they don't survive when-- the loss of a child. I don't know if me and my husband will survive this.
而且这正在摧毁我们的家庭。它正在造成我和我丈夫之间的紧张关系。大多数家庭，失去了孩子的父母，当——失去孩子时他们无法挺过来。我不知道我和我丈夫是否能挺过这一关。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: At the end of her statement, they cued up the ukulele video, and right before they hit Play, the judge interrupted.
在她声明的最后，他们播放了尤克里里视频，就在他们按下播放键之前，法官打断了。
What I want to know, though, in addition to everything that you've already testified to, is what you think about the plea agreement.
不过，除了你已经作证的所有内容之外，我想知道的是，你对这份认罪协议怎么看。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: I would like that the 10-year that attorneys are going to be fighting for, I would like that to be taken into consideration.
我希望律师们争取的那10年，能够被考虑进去。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: She asked for a parole restriction, not a trial.
她请求的是假释限制，而不是审判。
You may step down.
你可以下去了。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Only a few people spoke on Sunny's behalf. They emphasized what a good mother she was. They said she should get a shorter prison term so that she can return to her kids sooner.
只有几个人为Sunny辩护。他们强调她是个多么好的母亲。他们说她应该得到较短的刑期，以便她能尽快回到孩子身边。
Her defense attorney said that Sunny was a victim, too. Her husband was abusive. The night Sunny killed Mika, she was escaping a domestic violence incident. He was the white supremacist, the attorney said, not Sunny. She shouldn't be the one who shoulders all the blame.
她的辩护律师说Sunny也是受害者。她的丈夫虐待她。Sunny杀死Mika的那晚，她正在逃离一场家庭暴力事件。律师说，白人至上主义者是他，而不是Sunny。她不应该成为那个背负所有罪责的人。
And she shouldn't have to be punished for the ways the justice system failed Mika's family. Then she passed it off to Sunny, who stood facing the judge. She wore a cream-colored blouse and read from a piece of paper.
而且她不应该因为司法系统辜负Mika家庭的方式而受到惩罚。然后她把话语权交给Sunny，Sunny面对法官站着。她穿着一件奶油色的衬衫，拿着一张纸读着。
I want to start by saying, I take responsibility for my actions in these matters.
我想首先说，我对我这些事项中的行为承担责任。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: She immediately started talking about her own kids, how she was still breastfeeding her youngest, how she was staying sober for them. She didn't try to explain or deny her white supremacy affiliations, nor did she take full responsibility for killing Mika.
她立刻开始谈论她自己的孩子，她是如何还在哺乳她最小的孩子，她是如何为了他们保持清醒。她没有试图解释或否认她的白人至上主义联系，也没有为杀害Mika承担全部责任。
To the family, friends, and loved ones of Mika Westwolf, I give my most sincerest apologies for the horrid pain and suffering that I played a part in causing you all. [CRYING]
对于Mika Westwolf的家人、朋友和亲人，我对我在你们所有人身上造成的恐怖痛苦和折磨表示最诚挚的歉意。（哭泣）
All right. Thank you. OK, is there any reason why sentence should not now be imposed?
好的。谢谢。好的，有什么理由不能现在判刑吗？
No, Your Honor.
没有，法官阁下。
Not from defense.
辩护方没有。
OK, so I am going to go along with the plea agreement.
好的，那么我将同意认罪协议。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Sunny would spend 10 years in prison. But there was still the question of whether or not she could get parole before then. The judge addressed Sunny directly.
Sunny将在监狱里待10年。但关于她是否能在10年内获得假释的问题仍然悬而未决。法官直接向Sunny喊话。
I do not find your version of events credible. This is simply you continuing to mitigate your responsibility and blaming others for what you did. So therefore, having been found guilty of count one, vehicular homicide while under the influence, sentence is imposed as follows. The defendant shall be committed to the Montana State Prison for 25 years, with 15 of those years suspended, on the following conditions. The defendant shall be ineligible for parole for a period of 10 years.
我不认为你讲述的事件版本是可信的。这只是你继续减轻你的责任，并为你的所作所为指责别人。因此，在被判定犯有第一项过失车辆杀人罪（受药物影响）后，判决如下：被告将被送往蒙大拿州监狱，刑期25年，其中15年缓刑，条件如下。被告在10年内不得申请假释。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Ineligible for parole-- they had won. Carissa reached for Kevin's hand, leaned into him. They stayed seated as their relatives huddled around to embrace them.
不得申请假释——他们赢了。Carissa伸手去抓Kevin的手，靠向他。他们坐着不动，亲属们簇拥过来拥抱他们。
You are remanded to the custody of the Lake County Sheriff for transportation to the Montana State Prison. All right. Anything further? All right. Thank you. We are adjourned for the day.
你被移交给莱克县治安官羁押，转送至蒙大拿州监狱。好的。还有什么吗？好的。谢谢。今天休庭。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Sunny was handcuffed and led out the door. Carissa finally stood and gave Lapotka a long hug. People streamed out around them, glassy-eyed. Some supporters from the overflow room rushed Kevin. They said he should run for office. He seemed lighter than I'd ever seen him and surprised by the judge's ruling.
Sunny被戴上手铐，领出门去。Carissa终于站起来，给了Lapotka一个长时间的拥抱。人们从他们身边流出，眼神呆滞。一些从溢出房间的支持者冲向Kevin。他们说他应该竞选公职。他看起来比我见过的任何时候都要轻松，对法官的裁决感到惊讶。
In a sense, justice prevailed, you know? It's the best we can hope for. [LAUGHS]
在某种意义上，正义得到了伸张，你知道吗？这是我们能希望的最好的结果。（笑）
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Outside, at the red teepee, there was hot chocolate.
在外面，红色圆锥形帐篷那里，有热巧克力。
Anybody got a mug? Anyone?
有人有杯子吗？有人吗？
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Carissa gave another speech, then checked in with all the television reporters.
Carissa又做了演讲，然后与所有的电视记者对接。
(SUBJECT) CARISSA HEAVY RUNNER: Those that gave testimony, we did what we came here to do today. Thank you so much.
那些提供了证词的人，我们今天做了我们来这儿要做的事。非常感谢。
[WHOOPING, CHEERING]
（欢呼、喝彩）
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Every time they'd won something they didn't expect to win, Carissa told me she felt bittersweet. She pushed so hard to show other families that they deserved justice. And now here she was, getting what other families didn't get. Throughout the testimony, I kept looking at Bonnie, Maureena's mother, wondering what she was thinking.
每当他们赢得了他们没预料到会赢的结果时，Carissa告诉我她感到苦乐参半。她非常努力地向其他家庭展示他们应该得到正义。而现在，她得到了其他家庭没有得到的结果。在整个作证过程中，我一直看着Maureena的母亲Bonnie，好奇她在想什么。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: How did it feel for you to hear Sunny White admit to killing Mika?
听到Sunny White承认杀害Mika，你感觉如何？
It felt really good. It felt good. I heard her voice shake a little bit. I pictured the girl that hit my daughter. I pictured her being up there. I told myself that was OK if that didn't happen for me. I don't have to know why things happened. It just was-- I cried of happiness when I left. (EMOTIONALLY) There is some things, some justice you could get from other people's winnings.
感觉真的很好。感觉很好。我听到她的声音颤抖了一点。我脑海中浮现出那个撞倒我女儿的女孩。我脑海中浮现出她站在那儿的样子。我告诉自己，如果这事儿没发生在我身上也行。我不必知道为什么事情会发生。那只是——我离开时因为快乐而哭了。（情绪化）有些正义，你可以从别人的胜利中获得。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Tricia, Aiden's mom, didn't go to the sentencing. She's the one Lapotka told he couldn't file charges because the statute of limitations had passed.
Aiden的妈妈Tricia没去量刑听证会。她就是Lapotka告诉过因为诉讼时效已过而无法提起诉讼的那个人。
I wanted to go. Carissa asked me to go. And then my stomach just-- it was probably anxiety or stress.
我想去。Carissa让我去。然后我的胃就——那可能是焦虑或压力。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: I asked Tricia how she felt about the outcome.
我问Tricia对结果感觉如何。
Mixed. Mixed emotions, you know. Happy, mad.
混合的。混合的情绪，你知道吗。开心，愤怒。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: And mad because?
愤怒是因为？
Because--
因为——
Why can't it be you?
为什么不能是你？
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Why can't it be you? That's Trisha's mom, Georgi. They were sitting next to each other on the couch.
为什么不能是你？那是Tricia的妈妈，Georgi。她们并排坐在沙发上。
Yeah. I'm-- I'm sorry.
是的。我……我很抱歉。
(INTERVIEWER) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: No, it's OK.
没关系。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Georgi went to the sentencing hearing instead of Tricia.
Georgi去了量刑听证会，而不是Tricia。
It gives me hope that Aiden's going to be next, that there will be some justice.
这给了我希望，Aiden会是下一个，会有一些正义。
I mean, that's cool. I mean, I pretty much don't have hope anymore. But I don't want you to not have hope. I don't want Audrey to not have hope.
我的意思是，那很酷。我的意思是，我基本上再也没有希望了。但我不想让你没有希望。我不想让Audrey没有希望。
(HOST) SIERRA CRANE MURDOCH: Audrey is her daughter. Tricia's marriage didn't survive Aiden's death. She told me it wasn't just grief. It was the way grief turned her into a different person, an angrier person, a person exhausted from pushing for answers. This is how grief affected all of the other parents I met, which makes what Carissa and Kevin did feel even more extraordinary.
Audrey是她的女儿。Tricia的婚姻在Aiden去世后没能维持。她告诉我那不仅仅是悲伤。悲伤把她变成了一个不同的人，一个更愤怒的人，一个从争取答案中筋疲力尽的人。这就是悲伤如何影响了我遇到的所有其他家长，这让Carissa和Kevin所做的一切感觉更加非同寻常。
But it cost them, too. A week after sentencing, I got a text from Carissa. She and Kevin broke up. When I talked to her, she wasn't sure what was going to happen between them. She said they were working on it. For the anniversary of Mika's death last month, Carissa told Kevin she wanted to spend the day in the mountains, just them and their son, as a family.
但这也让他们付出了代价。量刑一周后，我收到了Carissa的短信。她和Kevin分手了。当我与她交谈时，她不确定他们之间会发生什么。她说他们正在努力解决。对于上个月Mika去世的周年纪念日，Carissa告诉Kevin她想在山上待一天，只有他们一家三口。
Sierra Crane Murdoch. She's writing a new book, and a big part of it is this case. Her first book-- if you liked this story, you will really like that one. It's called Yellow Bird-- Oil, Murder, and a Woman's Search for Justice in Indian Country. It was a finalist for the Pulitzer Prize.
我是Sierra Crane Murdoch。她正在写一本新书，其中很大一部分内容就是这个案子。她的第一本书——如果你喜欢这个故事，你会真的很喜欢那一本。书名叫《Yellow Bird——印第安国家的石油、谋杀与一个女性对正义的追求》。它曾入围普利策奖决赛。
Our program was produced today by Miki Meek. Dana Chivvis edited the show. The people who put together today's program include Jendayi Bonds, Michael Comite, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Angela Gervasi, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天的节目由Miki Meek制作。Dana Chivvis编辑了该节目。今天制作团队的人员包括Jendayi Bonds, Michael Comite, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Angela Gervasi, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Julie Whitaker 和 Diane Wu。我们的执行主编是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的资深编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。
Special thanks today to the Fund for Investigative Journalism, Sarah Twoteeth, Bryan Dupuis, Cheryl Horn, Dave Blanchard, and Becky Blanchard and family. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Quick program note-- we keep doing these bonus episodes every two weeks for our Life Partners. The latest one, I do a stand-up set on stage. If you're curious about all this and want to become a Life Partner, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners.
今天特别感谢调查新闻基金、Sarah Twoteeth、Bryan Dupuis、Cheryl Horn、Dave Blanchard、Becky Blanchard及家人。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。简短的节目通知——我们为我们的“生活伙伴”每两周制作一次加更剧集。最新一期，我在舞台上表演单口相声。如果你对这一切感到好奇并想成为“生活伙伴”，请访问thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Every day, I see him in the hallway here at the office. He always says the same exact thing to me.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。每天，我在办公室的走廊里看到他。他总是对我重复同样的话。
I'm not a white supremacist covering up a homicide for my white supremacist friend.
“我不是一个为白人至上主义朋友掩盖谋杀案的白人至上主义者。”
I believe you, Torey. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我相信你，Torey。我是Ira Glass。下周将带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[ACOUSTIC MUSIC]
（原声音乐）